hey I'm Reba my favorite movie of all
times is the sound of music I grew up in
a little bitty town in southeastern
Oklahoma called chalky we had about 18
people in the town when we were in
school every grade they would say who
wants to sing a solo at the Christmas
program right the Easter probe
Thanksgiving program and I got to sing
my favorite things these are a few of my
favorite what I had grown up listening
to was country music and so my favorite
things is totally different from
anything else I've ever sung before that
wasn't the kind of songs that the
McIntyre's would sing in the car going
to a rodeo and that was more my music
and that was one of the first songs that
I learned how to play also was on the
piano I will never forget the first time
I got to see The Sound of Music to see
the Alps through that movie it was
incredible and to this day that's still
a place I want to go see
[Music]
I traveled in movies you can learn so
much we went to movies for entertainment
and literally we know how much we were
learning doremi possible SoDo now
through that movie of Sound of Music
learned so much about the history and
how people were treated during the war
to see how people reacted in their
everyday lives that was very educational
for me it was an eye-opener a great
movie can expand your way of thinking
can make you really dive into something
and say wow I'm still a huge movie fan
it's great entertainment but very
educational - I love movies take one
that's a wrap
[Music]
[Music]
you